[音楽]
ん
ni
me
[音楽]
みなさんこんにちはー
株式会社火を焚いたという行く
市川されてですどうぞよろしくお願いします
私の仕事は
噴水やです
箱の中から煙モクモクん
マミの上食材とかのっけから下げたりして
これから仕事をしてい
私はそもそも
そうですね10隻かなりぐらいの小さな
飲食店の店主でした
を見せろ特色を
オーダーさんに
燻製料理をメニューの中にいたのがあって
最初は
ソーセージとか
話があっ
スペルのか
一般的な
コードを作っています
子供を
ダンサー
お客さんに the sea を出したいん
梅干し燻製してみたい
拉致を完成してみたい
話面タイプ燻製してみたりします
だんだん第疲れるしてきて
正味はの子にはまりましたエバー群生したいん
塩田光
保証だよっ
ミソだった
コックである僕は
仕事がもう一つあります
食べ歩きです
自分にかけられる行った時に
歩いたから sunday
荒削りのかつお節を完成してお醤油に漬け込んだと言う
せーの勝負です
僕は省力衝撃を受けました
そして一つの阿山町冠したんですね
感じだったんですよ
あれ
期待の燻製されている
おかしいと僕やったことがないん
b 2
そして
来栖会をずっと研究したですねきたりね
電話僕は
できた4分制することができています
僕には対処し日でしたらほんとん
はい
来る風生することで何が起こるのか
目算をかける
お寿司とかオサシンも燻製の香りが楽しめる
液状納涼に
シチューとかカレーとかもスモーキーになります
僕のオススメは
卵かけご飯あっ
生学のすごくいい
こんなのの燻製の液体ないからできます
燻製
実は1万年前からあるといわれている
陶芸
人類が日の発見
自分で取扱量になってから
それから
純正はあります
いる中発見
チンパンジーと人類を開けるきっかけなど止めろ
日は私たちを温めてくれます
そして超
濡れた体を乾燥させずれたり服も乾燥させていく
嫌がります会議
私はが夜間生活を手に入れました
そして外敵から海の国を守る安全も
そして q 3
セロリは
虫除けにもなります仲間たちがどこにいるのか
同市ですね
目印にもなろう
そして
燻製
保存というものも展示です
では重い
菌類は
カンカンは手に入れられなかったはずです
そもそも信金案件は飾るのかあさん
ら具合あっ
そういった所で発見されるという
それを
中に収めるん
人間は
すっごいをしています
10回20回百貨痩せるかじゃないよじゃないです
何万回そして何世代にも歌って
私たちが今イチ便利で一人を食べることもできる
でも推理秋が好きです
ホックプレートねー
みんなでな傾向を楽しむこともできます
でもやっぱりバーベキューのほうが楽しいです
季ぶりや
燻製の香りはもしかしたら私たちの遺伝子に組み込まれたん
全員の食の香りがあるかもしれません
以上
としてますけれども
この数字
なんだかわかりますかってわかるわけないことで普通に発表しますけど
これ
先ほどもせました私が液体を燻製するまでに失敗逆さ
何度も何
この以上としているのはこれぐらいじゃないからです
多分正解3年間であります
すごい苦労しました
でも人からは苦労したで努力したいん
言われていますそして私は1500回
以上行ったことで
液体を燻製すること天佑なんです
そしてもう一つくさんになるのかな
て気が出ません
それが
液体文政する方法とそのスゴ子の仏教です
はい私はコンクリートの特許です
みんな努力したね苦労したねって言われるそうに来ることは僕の黒はしたんですん
そんなに苦労と思っています
すごい楽しいなんです
努力はクローズ型デイ
ちゃえトライアンフれ楽しい人ということ
さて揉まれましたけれども人生には
ものすごい壁があります
それは高い壁かもしれませんし
すごく重いものかもしれません
沢山の
扉が用意されている壁かもしれませんし
大きな扉があってそれがすごい思えなんですよ
でもこの壁には必ずどこか
開くところがあるんです
かがらず
僕は
くん青春旅
母違えしたんですけれども
その感じだよ僕の原料つ原動力になりました
必ず答えはある
この日だ
新たにからここが正解かもしれん
新たにはもう星考えます
人それぞれ生から違いますでも必ず
田必ずどこか開くんです思えのかもしれません
開けてみないとその先はは買う
そうぞこんなふうに人生にあり
大カメなります最初は小さい力でしか押せない一緒になります
そしてこの数がないままこのだけじゃいくつもいくつも開かれた目があるとしている
そのうち力をつけています
そして
この辺があるんじゃないかなっていうのもわかるよ思っています
うんとか
方向要するに
ちゃ
っていうのは実はその日にこういうプロ4の村橋が
足つぼ図クラッ
転がってますでもなぁでチャンスが自分のものにできない
言えないです
その扉を開けてないかん
この中でするのっているわけです
お持ちですからこんな経験があると思うんですね
運転教えてい
する時間でもあ俺も曇ってしまう
あ
自分の膣の奥まで消
こんな経験ありませんか
こうやってそのクルマを手に入れた人間しか見えないん
ゴロゴロゴロゴロコロコロ転がっているのにその人にしかわからないん
この中です
自分の車か分からないん
こういうふうにザーッってこの頃困ってるんですか
この車をという
んですかね
先ほどの日
頭だった
まだ未経験の僕らにはこういうふうにでいる
でも
成功車
成功者からはあ
こうやって見えてるんだろうでしょう
あそこが当たりだあそこ7
でも
その製鋼所がこの壁このふと部屋で成功したのです
あなたの成功とは違う話だから漠然と
言葉で歌いてくる
マイケル除去音声
一歩一歩
どんなことでも
何かを達成する時には8作つい
するしかない
打倒変化
待ってんだから人にも
なんかこの時でもそれは努力者の
僕の好きな
ページ
私たちになっています
あっん
成功の確実な方法
もう一度だけもう一度だけ
その扉を救っ
私は今
自分で食べますツリー
自分で扉を作ります
今職員政府をしていますけれども
今度は
液体運勢の王がゆく初期
指打差を追った
海外
発信したい飾った
控除によっ
それから
燻製の世界ではまだあげない
香り数時間
雇用して私は世界に発信してきた
燻製を規格基準だしたいと考
まだまだ先は長いですでもチャレンジ
持ってこれ面白い
そういうふうに考えます
皆さんの目の前
壁はいくつもあると思います
高いところもありますし重い壁もあります扉がいくつもあるんだった
その時だ
私は
まだ成功者ではありません
ただ一つ
これだけは皆さんにアドバイスできると思います
そのためを押しましょう
p あり